fred a little timpani i'm bringing back
flirty gary the alter ego known as
flirty flop flow fly if you remember
flirty gary is always looking for love
if you want a little refresher robin
here he is the everyone loves one
gathering
history the history of flirty gary
uh this is flirty gary picking up the
old woman
yeah hello hi i'm gary
but the ladies call me flirty g you know
how old i am
maybe i'm 83. i want to give you the
early bird special what does that mean
that's where i eat you out every
afternoon at 4 30. oh that's the perfect
time for me because i go to bed at nine
flirty gary he is good so we got curious
this time around for brand new flirty
gary
how would flirty gary do in the gay
community
we're very very into the gay community
we've only dealt with him
and women before well we got a picture
of gary we created a fake profile for
him on grindr
he almost looks like el chapo then yeah
he's all choppers
gary's profile bio read hello hello baba
bissell in the house looking to meet
some fun
guys and have some cray-cray fun oh my
god gary told me he had to go to his
wife
because really he's right he was putting
up a grinder
right profile so when your neighbors
call your wife and go listen i i have
bad news
gary's on grind are looking for dudes
your husband's gay yeah
gary was it diff like did you explain it
to your wife and she got it or was she
like this is kind of creepy
she looked at me and she goes really and
i go yeah because for the show she goes
whatever yeah sure for the show
right it's work i want to see some of
the guys honey i'm going on a gay
dating app for the show for the show
let me see they got wow boy look at that
guy's rock hard abs
look at you gary gary look at gary all
proud gary you'd be a winner in the gay
community
i have never seen the profile oh really
he's handling my account
yeah really mary i'm not even on it
within one week gary received over 75
different private message requests
he received 42 unsolicited dick pics
you'd be so sore right now and 30
full-on ass and [ __ ] shots
really oh chris put this together were
you jealous of the guys gary was getting
jealous he was getting guys that turned
me down
he kept calling them daddy gary oh
really yeah
howard i don't know i got into this a
little bit more than i thought
yeah at one point you know chris put up
a picture of me and i go
that picture's terrible so i made him
change the picture right i was like i'm
better so i need to put this picture
look out look how much thinner gary
looks in this picture from the one i
know he's
25 pounds again
this is a fantasy right but i'm telling
you like i would be out
and it would be going off off off it
wasn't for you it was foreign
do your sons know that you're daddy gary
on grindr they do not
wait till they find out why not tell the
boys so make sure they know
you got to tape that conversation you'd
be like
dad why are you cleaning your throat i'm
a
little
i'm a little nervous boys what is it dad
uh i'm gonna come out to you right now
and i'm
i'm on grinder gary